[Music]
the Internet's median John Oliver issued
a call to action on net neutrality on a
recent edition of last week tonight
he urged people to flood the Federal
Communications Commission with comments
to defend the regulation well today's
some of the biggest tech companies like
Facebook and Google are participating
what they call a day of action it is a
protest of the FCC's plan to rollback
Obama era net neutrality rules now the
rules adopted in 2015 increased
government oversight and required online
service providers to treat all Internet
traffic the same they prohibit the
slowing or blocking of websites content
while treating other sites differently
but in May the republican-led FCC voted
to start changing net neutrality rules
CBS News contributor Nicholas Thompson
is editor in chief of Wired and joins us
at the table
hey Nick good morning Connie first give
us a net neutrality 101 lesson very
quickly and why it matters so net
neutrality is the principle that all the
information that flow over the pipes
that come on to your computer right so
when you type in a website information
flows there are pipes it comes to a
computer net neutrality is the principle
that all that information has to be
treated the same so the companies that
own the pipes can't say you know what we
don't want that website to be fast we
want that one to be slow and we don't
like what that one is saying so we're
gonna stop it all together and maybe
you'd like a tiered plan so you can get
Wikipedia right so net neutrality is a
very important principle to people on
the Internet
so who are the companies that are
pushing a repeal of net neutrality no
the people who own the pipes right
Verizon Comcast Time Warner Cable AT&T
though their position is kind of
complicated right now but basically if
you own pipes you want to be able to
make a lot of money off of them by
charging websites to travel it up and
they're pointers that we own and we can
do we should be able to do what we want
with them and the government should be
involved and if we make more money we'll
invest more heavily in them and you'll
get faster speeds we have had the
principle of net neutrality though
almost since the beginning of the
internet and it's flourished pretty
oh it's working out pretty well it's a
very innovative open space so we reached
out to the FCC and they said they did
not have a comment about the day of
action what's their argument well what
the FCC is saying is look number one
let's not regulate right in order to
protect the pipes and to make sure that
they're free you have to pass regulation
so if you're totally against regulation
you might say that number two they're
very close to the telecom companies they
want to do what's right for the telecom
companies they will argue that if you
give the telecom companies more freedom
to control their pipes
they'll innovate more what everybody
else is saying is no every time you
relax and let the telecom companies do
what they want they stifle innovation
it's not good for everyone and in fact
the sort of the core point of net
neutrality is that the Internet has been
a place of openness it's a place where
you can start a company where you can do
what you want and you can be reasonably
certain that if you put a website on the
Internet people will be able to get to
it but if we don't have net neutrality
and you start a company that is opposed
to something that Comcast is running and
it's a competitor to something that Time
Warner Cable has they can shut you down
so it's not just competition it's the
entire principle of the internet that's
why people are so riled up about that
have Facebook and Google have a
complicated relationship with net
neutrality they do because all of their
engineers are in favor of it and the
corporate executives maybe they like
rules that favor big companies so
they're in a complicated spot that they
are behind this today all right Nick
Thompson thank you very much thank you